it's not just that age thing yeah
superior in so many ways and he has to
remain humble you might think that
Governor Andrew Cuomo and CNN anchor
Chris Cuomo are hamming it up for the
cameras with all that lovable brotherly
bickering like this this isn't a
flattering picture
I did not pick this picture with your
mouth open but it is suitable in some
ways and this you have formal primetime
I have Cuomo all the time but on
Wednesday Andrew appeared on Late Night
with Seth Meyers and explained how real
their sibling rivalry really is we're
playing it down it's temporary it's the
it's the nice version it's the inviting
my tongue version because he takes
advantage of me in that situation you
know right a certain amount of license
he can say what he wants to say I have
to be gubernatorial and respectful so he
uses it of course
Andrews talking about the fact that
Chris has his own show on CNN Cuomo
prime time which Andrew regularly
appears on I'm in field the brother and
you know as an older brother it's our
familial and biological duty to assert
dominance over the younger brother to
keep them humble keep them in their
place it was certain intellectual
dominance physical dominance athletic
dominance all of which happens to be
true between me and my brother look up
busting your chops in the dictionary and
you might just find the brothers Cuomo
it's not just that age thing yeah
superior in so many ways and he has to
remain humble yeah so the two might
playfully butt heads but there's clearly
a lot of love there we're talking about
my my brother talking about my little
brother this is my best friend
on Wednesdays Cuomo prime time Andrew
and Chris shared a pretty sweet moment
at the end of yet another combative
interview Governor Andrew Cuomo are you
dealing with very important things I
know that you don't take yourself
seriously but you take the job very
seriously that's what this situation
demands yeah it's the cute brotherly
moments like that that has America
totally
swooning over the Cuomo brothers I love
you thank you for coming on the show
love you all right love you brother the
Cuomo craze has gotten so big the term
Cuomo sexuals was coined for their fan
base which includes stars like Jada
Pinkett Smith I don't miss a press
conference when Cuomo's on I'm I've Turk
I'm like got to go see my celebrity
crush right now sorry and Trevor Noah
there's a group of women who came out
and they said we we're falling in love
with Palmer and I said well yeah
everyone everyone said we have
homosexual in that way a source
previously told et the brothers are
aware of the Cuomo crush and hashtag
Cuomo brothers they think it's cute and
playful and despite the Internet's total
obsession with them they're not letting
the hype distract them from all the work
that must get done both brothers know
the responsibility they have during this
global crisis and they take their job
seriously
chris has lighthearted moments during
interviews with his brother but isn't
afraid to ask him tough questions and
hold him accountable yeah some say I
shouldn't come on this show because you
harassed me too much fear sent out a
really me can't take it want a pat on
the back but back to our regularly
scheduled program Chris straight-up
asked his brother about his newfound
popularity on air and it was epic do you
think that you are an attractive person
now because you're single and ready to
mingle do you really think you are some
desirable single person and that this is
not just people's pain coming out of
them I think you're a beauty is in the
eye of the beholder listen to you you
got an answer for anything you're
feeling pretty good about yourself in
April et chatted with Chris's wife
Christina who weighed in on all the love
her hubby and brother-in-law are getting
the brotherly like chiding that we've
all fallen in love with on TV all the
time yeah they're always taking digs at
each other and it's hilarious and it
always provides for entertainment at
family functions and they love each
other to death Chris learned a lot from
him
and you know they kind of finish each
other sentences and you know they you
know they ingest and it's it provides
for a lot of entertainment it's really
nice that they're sharing it with
everyone else now
so girls feel a little relief from their
anxiety through some humor
I've seen so many people commenting
saying you know we love them we love the
brotherly love and yes they're cute that
hashtag go mo crush and you guys scream
that damage but some people at the Cuomo
sectional t-shirts yeah they're
hilarious I love them I have someone
sending me a sweater that says bad and
then I had I mean it then we should get
some masks made right
[Music]